If you want to hear how the next Stephen King
remake may be teased at the end of It: Chapter
2, then stick around to the end of this video.
Welcome to Things You Missed, I am traveling
this week so I’m not in the studio, but
I did get my own copy of It Chapter 2, so
I scrubbed through it and found, surprisingly,
a lot more that I hadn’t caught in theaters.
So if you haven’t seen my original 71 Things
You Missed, I’d recommend you watch that
one first, but assuming you have seen it,
let’s get into the Things You Missed.
[THINGS YOU MISSED]
One thing I brought up when covering the first
It was the constant cosmic references that
set up Pennywise’s origins from outer space
in the second movie, and I did notice some
teases in the second chapter as well.
The Ferris Wheel at the Festival is called
the Astro, the carnival mural features sun
and moon paintings and we can see that Eddie’s
phone is a Galaxy S8.
This all ties into the Ritual of Chud, which
they eventually use to try to defeat It.
In the novel, the backstory is expanded and
we learn about the ancient rivalry between
It, and it’s rival, Maturin the Turtle.
I pointed out some references to the Turtle
in the last video, but I found even more,
such as this one in Henry’s room at the
asylum.
Mike also speaks of a root that the native
americans believed has mystic properties,
which he also puts in Bill’s drink so that
he too can see the Ritual of Chud.
Roll it.
"Their holy man.
Their holy of holies.
He took me in.
Fed me their sacred Maturin.”
The turtle isn’t refered to as Maturin in
the novel It, but we learn of the name Maturin
and more lore in Stephen King’s Dark Tower
series.
We first meet adult Bill on the set of the
movie he’s adapting from his own novel,
Attic Room.
If you pause here you can get a better look
at the book version, and it’s massive, much
like the novel It, and there’s a forward
by someone named Jason Ballantine.
When we later see the copy of his other book,
The Black Rapids, Jason Ballantine is also
responsible for the forward.
This is a reference to the editor of both
It and It Chapter 2.
Usually when we see a crew member referenced like that,
the art department makes references to themselves,
so I think it’s nice that the editor got
some love in this one.
This next part is something that I did notice
in the theaters, but I almost couldn’t believe
my own eyes, and ultimately just thought I
must have imagined it, and thus didn’t put
it the previous episode.
So the movie they are shooting is called Attic
Room at Warner Bros studios, but on this camera
tape, the memo doesn’t say Attic Room, it
says, Attic Panic.
But what is Attic Panic?
Well, It Chapter 2 takes place in 2016, and
one big horror movie that Warner Bros released
in 2016 is Lights Out, directed by David Sandberg,
who was hired after posting his short film
Lights Out to YouTube and it being massively
successful.
One of his other shorts on his YouTube channel
is called Attic Panic.
If you’ve seen my episode on Annabelle:
Creation, you know that many of the concepts
from Attic Panic made it into Annabelle: Creation
as well, which of course, is made by Warner
Bros.
The date on this label is 10/10/2018, which
is obviously impossible since the film takes
place in 2016, but probably is just a fun
little reference to the day this scene of
IT was actually shot, since we can literally
see it says IT 2 right here.
I’ve also already pointed out this cameo
by Peter Bogdonovich, but not the fact that
he’s wearing a VISTOW pin.
Vistow stands for Volunteers In Service To
Orson Welles a reference to another movie
where Bogdonovich plays a director.
When Mike calls up the other losers, his area
code is from Bangor, Maine.
The novel It was written in Bangor, and it’s
said to serve as an inspiration for many of
the locations in Derry, and speaking of Derry,
when Richie is about to go on stage at the
comedy club, a poster in the background says
“Home We Go” foreshadowing the homecoming
that the Losers Club would soon face.
The next one we meet is Ben, and one of his
employees in the board meeting is played by
Brandon Crane, the very same Brandon Crane
who played the 12 year old Ben Hanscom in
the original 1990 adaptation of It.
After being introduced to the adult Losers
Club, there’s one more adult version we
meet.
Other than Greta Keene, I guess.
I’m talking about Henry Bowers, who is locked
up in Juniper Hills Mental Hospital, where
some of the other patients are watching an
episode of Tom and Jerry.
This particular clip shows a piece of meat
going down into the sewers, just Derry’s children
are food that is lured into the sewer system
by Pennywise.
One of the new aspects of Richie’s character
in Chapter 2 is the fact that he is revealed
to be bi-sexual.
There are actually some hints about this early
on.
At the Chinese restaurant, he asks Eddie if
he’s married, before clarifying, “What? To a
woman?”
Then he addresses Ben’s weightloss.
"Wait, let's talk about the elephant not in the room.
You're hot.
You're like every Brazilian soccer player wrapped up into one person.
At the end of that meal, Mike fills them all
in on It, and shows off a couple pages of
his book.
The novel It is broken up by these interludes
written by Mike that provide exposition about
the Derry and about the monster.
The film offers little glimpses of details
about It, like this page that discusses Le
Loup Garou, the French werewolf slash skinchanger
that the kids discuss as they compare It to
legends in many other cultures in Chapter
13 of the novel.
We can also see some other thoughts from Mike
that I just found interesting, like him questioning
if the deadlights are a hallucination, or
his plans to save up money to leave Derry
when this is all over, which he does.
At the end of the movie we get another look
at this book, where we see Mike describing
the bird form of It, which is his biggest
fear in the book, and also there’s a map
of the proximity between where Adrian Mellon
is found compared to where the lumberjacks
are found in 1879, something I discussed in
greater detail in the Pennywise Horror History.
Back at the hotel, Ben and Beverly talk in
the bar, and one of the bottles in the background
resembles a clown from the clown room in Chapter
One.
And as long as I’m talking about connections
to Chapter One, you know the music that plays
during Penny’s infamous dance scene?
We can hear that again as Bill runs into the
funhouse at the Derry Canal Days Festival.
I also pointed out director Andy Muschietti’s
cameo in the first video, what I didn’t
realize is what he’s browsing in the pharmacy.
Like Beverly Marsh in the first movie, he’s
eyeing a box of tampons.
By the way, after seeing my first video on
It Chapter 2, Andy DMed me with a couple of
additional easter eggs.
“The little bully kid at the opening is
played by Katie LUnman, aka, Betty Ripsom
in Chapter 1”.
He also hints that The Abbey Road album cover
featured Paul McCartney walking barefoot.
Conspiracy theories said Paul was DEAD and
that was a signal.
There’s a shot in the movie where one of
the adult losers is barefoot.
Who is it?
The answer being Ben, did surprise me, though
technically you do see Stan’s barefoot as
he gets in the tub, but he’s completely
naked, so not sure if that counts.
One thing I was interested to take a closer
look at was the bathroom stall that Beverly
is thrown into for her encounter with It.
Unfortunately, I wasn’t able to find a lot
of meaning in most of the graffiti, but here
are the ones I found most interesting.
The right side is all about BJs, and one of
the messages says, “BJ’s, call CLOWNS”.
So take that how you will.
Another says, “your father is proud of you”,
perhaps this is a mock insult about Bev’s
dad, or maybe it just ties into the aforementioned
BJs, as kind of a joke.
Then there are what seems to be three clues
about how to defeat It.
The first says, "with the lights out it's
less dangerous."
Then there's one that says, "smaller the better".
And then finally, "big is what it seems."
If you find anything interesting, drop me
a comment, but I'm moving on to the plethora
of references to other works.
The first one is this name plate at the library
which says Wendy Torrance, the name of the
Mom from The Shining, which is also written
by Stephen King.
Then in the movie theater arcade, we see the
remains of a poster for the Avengers.
No, not the one you just thought of, I’m
talking about the 1998 film The Avengers.
I haven’t seen the movie, so I can’t say
much more than that, but it does add weight
to my theory that the movie theater closed
down in the year 1998.
In the junk shop that Stephen King’s character
works at there are a bunch of license plates,
one of which is CQB 241, the license plate
from another Stephen King story, Christine.
One thing I mentioned in the last video was
a newspaper headline mentioning someone named
Gillespie, and how it may have been a reference
to cop from Stephen King’s vampire novel
Salem’s Lot.
And after being able to pause and take a better
look at this text, it totally is a big reference
to Salem’s Lot.
The headline reads “Constable Gillespie’s
Investigation Widens”
Neighboring city turmoil forces officer into
toughest decision of his career.
This confirms that the events of Salem’s
Lot do take place in the nearby Jerusalem’s
Lot prior to the events of It, if we’re
going by the altered timeline of the Muschietti
It films and really seems to suggest that
Salem’s Lot will be the next Stephen King
novel slash TV movie to get the big Hollywood
treatment.
And by the way, it is.
James Wan’s name has been mentioned, as
has It Chapter 2 screenwriter Gary Dauberman.
My last Thing You Missed of the year, is kind
of a tragic one.
Stan, in his final letter, the last thing
he ever writes in his life, misspelled the
word lose.
"See, the thing about being a Loser is you don't have anything to lose."
Way to go out Stan.
Great going.
Check out the video on the left for the complete
history of Stan and other It Characters.
If you love horror, remember to subscribe
to CZsWorld for new horrors every week, ring
that deathbell for notifications, and I’ll
see you next year.
Assuming we both survive.